so this you really have to see to
believe this this is just out of this
world a bizarre Tucker Carlson the Fox
News propagandist has been promoting a
forthcoming then forthcoming special on
masculinity and testosterone that is
going to I guess shed light on the
crisis of masculinity that Tucker says
exists and uh talk about the issues with
decreased testosterone in men which we
will get to in a moment and it's all
really weird and one of the things that
many people noticed about the promo for
the thing was that it's quote homoerotic
now again like I don't I to say it's to
say something is homoerotic pejoratively
is kind of homophobic and I don't think
that's what the commentaries were here
it's pointing out this is all about
restoring men in the image that Tucker
Carlson and other right-wingers see men
as being expected to hold and yet the
promo
seemed much more in line maybe with uh I
I don't know with with gay men it's not
even really clear like exactly what the
commentary was but I'm going to play the
promo for you and it is certainly
strange it doesn't exactly seem like the
prototypical alpha male idea of Tucker's
audience so take a look at this to start
with
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so there's like a there was like a naked
guy with like a light on his testicles
and then now there's now there's like
half naked guys exercising
once the society collapses then
you're in half times well hot iron
sharpens iron as they say and those Hard
Times inevitably produce men who are
tough men who are resourceful men who
are strong enough to survive
and then they go on to re-establish
order and so the cycle begins again
[Applause]
the end of men is the is the name of it
and it all if I told if you told me
David check out this satire of a Fox
News special about masculinity and you
showed me that I'd go wow that's a
really funny satire but it's real so the
special has aired and there was a
fitness expert brought on to explain how
to raise testosterone levels in men and
the topic comes up of testicle tanning
tanning your testicles
you saw on the clip there if you want to
optimize and take it to another level
expose yourself to red light therapy yes
and the Juve that we were using in the
documentary there's a massive amount of
testicle tanning it's testicle tanning
but it's also full body uh red light
therapy which has massive amount of
benefits and there's so much data out
there that isn't being picked up on or
covered so obviously half the viewers
right now are like what that's quotation
that's crazy
but my view is okay testosterone levels
a crash and nobody says anything about
it that's crazy
so why is it crazy to seek Solutions
it's not crazy to seek Solutions and I
think I was recently exposed to a term
called bromopathy and I think there's a
lot of people out there right now that
um are don't trust the mainstream
information yeah now I wouldn't call it
bromopathy I think what he's looking for
is bromyopathy like Homeopathy either
way it's it's not very funny now
to be clear
red light therapy for testosterone is
being studied and there are reports
saying it might do something or it might
not but this isn't even a doctor this is
a guy branded a fitness professional and
the entire thing is so bizarre and they
always bring in this undertone we can't
trust the official stuff what we're
being told can't be believed so
therefore you got to start tanning your
balls bro and the next guest afterwards
was Kid Rock the right-wing musician and
he even Kid Rock was like is this all a
joke that's when you know it's weird
when even Kid Rock can't take it
seriously [ __ ] ladies and gentlemen so
our dude our cameraman fox is in your
house right now
yeah he is dude stop testicle tanning
come on
I mean yeah I haven't heard anything
open your mind Bobby
I'm I'm starting a punk rock band and
it's called testicle tanning that's the
end of it
I think you'll be massively successful
but I mean don't you think at this point
when so many of the therapies the paths
they've told us to take have turned out
to be dead ends that have really hurt
people why is Kid Rock being interviewed
about this like Kid Rock doesn't know
anything about media literacy Kid Rock
doesn't know anything about medicine
it's a crazy premise to bring on Kid
Rock to comment on testicle tanning
Fitness Pro why wouldn't
open-minded people seek new Solutions
I I don't know what the hell is going on
in this world I'm not even sure if I
understood that question but some days I
just want to stop exactly no he didn't
Kid Rock doesn't even understand the
question that Tucker Carlson is asking
him now let's interject some reality
here a good question is are the premises
even true our testosterone levels
decreasing now the answer is yes but
it's not exactly clear why or what it
means so there's been a bunch of studies
done over several decades and it does
appear as though testosterone levels are
decreasing in men at a given age like we
know about over time in for an
individual as one ages testosterone
levels decrease but there is something
different going on which is men of a
particular age today
seem to have slightly lower testosterone
levels than men of the same age at some
period in the past so it appears to be
decreasing then the question is why and
the cause is not actually known but
there's a bunch of different ideas one
aspect of this could be external toxins
and something environmental we know that
there's lots of products out there that
have endocrine disruption potential and
we know certain things can affect female
fertility so there could be things in
the environment that affect men's
testosterone levels that's one
possibility another piece appears to be
untreated depression we we have pretty
good data that untreated depression
pushes down testosterone levels we have
both stigma around mental health
treatment in the United States as well
as lack of access to mental health
treatment in the United States you don't
treat depression if depression decreases
decreases testosterone you would expect
to see decreased testosterone obesity is
very high in the United States and
moderate obesity seems to diminish ish
testosterone due to what's called
insulin resistance Associated reductions
in the sex hormone binding globulin okay
so that that maybe obesity may be a
factor here men with diabetes are more
likely to have low testosterone it's not
clear whether it's a cause effect
correlation causation so there is an
issue and it's being explored by medical
doctors a decrease in testosterone but
Tucker's friend Kid Rock and a fitness
professional aren't going to be the ones
to solve it they're also not the
authorities on this and the maybe the
most important thing is they frame this
as a cultural issue of [ __ ] men like
when the right talks about the end of
men and decrease testosterone they're
talking about [ __ ] men men that don't
meet the prototypical emblematic image
of what a manly man is supposed to be
what's particularly funny is Tucker
doesn't meet that stand standard either
right I mean like like I I don't care
about these uh standards and these ideas
but Tucker as the privileged sort of you
know I think Dandy might be the word
that's that's applied bow tie wearing I
mean he had you know tasseled in that
interview he had tasseled you you can
even kind of see it tasseled loafers
with no socks like he he's not the guy
that meets neither is Trump right and
that so that's what's also very strange
about this now just as a bonus clip
here's a preview of another upcoming
Tucker Carlson special where he brings
on two butchers to talk about the idea
that extraterrestrials are mutilating
cattle this is the next special you have
to have the right tools so and you have
to have the right knife with the right
Edge on it because if you don't have a
sharp knife you're never going to be
able to achieve you know you might be
able to achieve it but it but it's going
to look like you didn't know what you
were doing so right if these animals
have been found with their you know
these pieces surgically removed
and you know not making a lot of hack
marks when you're cutting somebody knows
what they're doing right so that that's
it to assess the difficulty here so
we've heard well it must be some satanic
cult that has been operating I guess for
centuries in countries around the world
but whoever's doing this knows a lot
about the anatomy of these animals in
his high skill is that correct yes and
frankly butchers with a skill level like
ours are becoming less and less frequent
in the United States so even finding a
butcher that God this is so stupid so
that's the next special the bearded
butcher twins or brothers will explain
to you how there are Cuts being made to
cattle that suggest maybe
extraterrestrial origin Fox News Tucker
Carlson specials specials which are now
airing one of our long time sponsors is
vincero collective if you don't know
vincero yet it's the place to go for
Quality watches sunglasses and more
serious style undeniable quality and
total versatility put vincero really at
the top of the game and their newest
watch release is no exception it's the
Argo automatic it spotlights everything
I love about vincero I got the Argo
automatic in Frost white this is a dive
watch which is of course a staple in the
watch world but I really think vincero
found a way to make this one stand out I
love the gradient blue accent of the
hour markers against the solid white
face I really love all of their watches
and I own a bunch but the Argo is
probably my favorite so far vincero
sunglasses and jewelry and other
accessories are awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero Collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman the link is down below